[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL VISENTIN:
So as Zak said, I'm
from DeepMind's
applied group, where
I work on a team that applies
DeepMind's research to machine
learning and
reinforcement learning--
DeepMind's research in machine
learning and reinforcement
learning to Google's products.
Today I'm going to
briefly talk to you
about why we chose to use
TensorFlow, how we use it,
and how it's helped us.
So the choice of a
numerical computing
platform such as TensorFlow
is incredibly important to us.
It's how we express our ideas,
and it's the piece of software
our engineers and
scientists spend most
of their time interacting with.
The quality of that platform has
a direct and significant effect
on the quality of our work
and the speed with which we
can deliver results.
And there are several aspects
to what we look for in that.
So from flexibility,
our researches
continue to concoct all these
weird and wonderful networks,
which we're hoping
to put into use.
Usability-- using this platform
has to be easy and natural.
Simple things like
getting some embeddings
and passing through a
feed-forward network
have to be trivial.
Composing things should be easy.
We should be able to take
all these components which
people are developing
and knock them together
to create new things.
We need to be able to reach
into the guts of that network
to see what it's doing, and
we need tools for visualizing
and debugging what's going on.
The platform also
has to be scalable.
We see this move towards
increasingly more data,
increasingly larger
networks trained
on more powerful accelerators
across multiple servers.
And the more that trend
continues, the better.
We need to be performant.
So training machine
learning models
is the new compile link cycle.
It often takes days
or even weeks for us
to get results, which reduces
the speed with which we
can iterate and try new things.
So the faster it goes,
the faster we can develop.
It's also important
at serve time,
where latency is a critical
factor in what we can do.
We often have quite
tight latency boundaries.
The more performant
the model is,
the more expressive and more
computationally powerful
models we can use, which will
give us bigger accuracy gains.
Also with training,
performance matters,
because when we're training
on real data at serve time,
the speed with
which we can train
affects the freshness
of the model, which
often has downstream effects
on our accuracy at serve time.
And finally,
production readiness--
we often spend all this time
doing research, and evaluation,
and experimentation
of our models.
And when we finally come
up with a good thing,
we want to get it into
production as soon
as possible to do
live experiments
and ultimately scale it up to
all the traffic that we have.
So previously at
DeepMind, our projects
were all implemented in
either Torch or Disbelief.
As TensorFlow began
to mature and head
towards its first
open source release,
we started looking at it
as an interesting thing.
In the applied group, we
began experimenting with it
by trying a few new projects.
Meanwhile, the
research team, who
have this very
stable, much used code
base they needed to
think about, began
by carefully evaluating the
suitability by reimplementing
several existing projects.
Based on the results
of that, we decided
that TensorFlow was
the way forward,
and so we started to migrate.
So over the past
year or so, we've
been working on that process.
And as of today, most of our
code that we currently use
is in TensorFlow.
And all the stuff--
the significant amount of stuff
we're building from now on
will be in TensorFlow.
What's quite cool about this is
we made this decision a year,
a year and a half ago, and
since then, the TensorFlow
and the ecosystem
around it has improved
beyond our expectations.
So we're even more
happy with this decision
now than we were then.
So I'm going to spend the
rest of my time talking
a bit more specifically
about how we use TensorFlow
and how it helps us.
And since I'm from the applied
group, I'll start there.
So one of the coolest
things we've done recently
is on optimizing the energy
usage in Google's data centers.
This began when the technical
infrastructure team came to us
after seeing the AlphaGo
matches and wondered
how we could use RL to
control the data centers more
efficiently.
So we work with them,
and subsequently worked
with teams in Google Brain
to build models to control
the cooling infrastructure.
Briefly, this is what a cold
aisle in one of Google's data
centers looks like.
This is the servers.
Some of them, maybe,
are running TensorFlow,
and they're getting
hot doing so.
So we have these fans
at the back, which
pull that cold air
over the servers
into this hot aisle, where it
travels down and is transferred
into a water cooling system.
So here are some
pipes and some pumps.
And the pipes take the hot
water from the hot aisle
to the chillers on the roof,
and the cold water from those
chillers back to the cold aisle.
And here's what those
cooling towers look like.
They're just big fans
which take the water
and cool it down into the air.
So we spent a while
working on this offline.
We had to take into
account safety.
The model couldn't go
and try random things,
otherwise we'd break
billion-dollar data centers,
which is never great.
And we had to work out how
to do a bit of exploration
as well, because if we
just learned on the data
which we had available,
the model would probably
never learn to do
anything more optimal
than what the human
operators had done.
So we iterated a bit,
and when it eventually
came time to experiment,
we turned it on,
and we saw this nice drop.
>From my experience, it's
kind of rare to see something
so defined and
sustained like this,
so we're quite happy with it.
So we had this initial
result, and it came time
to implement it.
Because the data
centers didn't really
have the infrastructure
set up to run, and train,
and evaluate, and verify
machine learning models,
we had to write a lot
of this ourselves.
So we did that.
We took our original
Torch models
and moved them to TensorFlow.
We built up all this
training, and validation,
and serving stuff.
But over the past
year, what we've
witnessed the development
in these high-level APIs
around TensorFlow and components
like TensorFlow Serving, which
basically negate a lot of
the work that we had to do,
which from our perspective
is great because we'd rather
focus on the modeling
aspects than all this kind
of infrastructure stuff.
Cool.
So another example
where TensorFlow
helped us is we
previously had this system
called Gorila, which stands for
general reinforcement learning
architecture, with some extra
letters thrown in there.
And we wrote this,
initially, to speed up
training of DQN style agents.
So what this was was a framework
built on top of disbelief.
We had the parameters
of an agent stored
across multiple
parameter servers,
and multiple instances
of that agent
pulling the parameters
from that parameter server
and interacting with
environments to get experience.
That experience was then stored
in a distributed memory where
multiple learners sampled
from it to make updates
to the model parameters.
And the whole thing kind
of cycled around like that.
By doing it this way, we
could get more experience
faster because we
had multiple agents,
and we could learn
faster because we
had multiple learners.
But often, more than the
speed of convergence,
we often saw that sometimes
these models actually
did better than models
trained on single servers.
And we think that
had something to do
with the breaking
of correlations
between the examples we
trained on from time to time.
This also was one
of the inspirations
for the A3C training algorithm,
which our researchers later
developed.
So with the introduction
of TensorFlow,
we were able to
basically deprecate this
because much of
the functionality
is handled by
TensorFlow or can be
written from within
TensorFlow, which is great
because it's less time
we need to spend on code
and maintaining it,
and more time we
can spend on our
actual projects.
More generally, since we've
started using TensorFlow,
we've seen a reduction
across the board
in the amount of ancillary
work we have to perform.
And things are only getting
better as TensorFlow
and the ecosystem around
it continues to develop.
So one of these is
the high-level APIs
which are developing, which take
care of a lot of the work we
previously had to do
to start a new project,
to build a prototype, to
train it and evaluate it,
meaning we can spend
more time on modeling.
It's easy to experiment
with models in TensorFlow.
It's easy to put together
a baseline in a couple
lines of code.
It's easy to change
things about it.
So for example, if we
have a bunch of embeddings
from various time
series, do we want
to concatenate the last
10 of them together?
Do we want to
convolve over them?
Do we want to pass them through
an LSTM to get the state?
It's all just a couple
of lines of changes,
which is quite nice.
The distributed
training helps us.
We can try more things
quicker and sooner.
And finally, once we've
gone through all this work
and we're excited and wanting
to put them all into production,
TF Serving kind of gets rid
of a lot of the pain that
was previously there.
So all this amounts to a quicker
development cycle, meaning we
can support more projects.
We can experiment more,
and we can deliver
quicker, which is great.
And what's more, we've yet to
come across an instance in any
of these collaborations
with Google
where TensorFlow
has not been suited
to the problem we're working
on, hasn't been flexible
enough, which is great.
So I'm excited about
the possibilities here,
and I hope we can tell you more
about some of these projects
soon.
So the applied team is
only one part of DeepMind,
and our friends in
research are also
busy doing lots of
cool stuff and have
begun to take advantage
of TensorFlow to do so.
So one of the obvious
things and one
of the most exciting
moments for us last year
was when AlphaGo succeeded
in a series of matches
against Lee Sedol, one of
the greatest Go players
of the last decade.
What made this so
exciting was it
was a combination of a
great technical achievement
in making a strong Go
player, but it also
represented something of a new
beginning in the game of Go.
Interest boomed.
Go boards sold out across the
world, which was interesting.
And players responded, not
with a sense of defeat,
but they were excited about
it as a new beginning,
because they could work
with these machines
to explore more deeply the
mysteries of this ancient game.
More to the point,
AlphaGo was one
of the first significant
uses of TensorFlow
at DeepMind, where it was
used to great advantage
to train these networks,
powering AlphaGo.
So I won't spend too much
time talking about Go itself.
Just suffice it it say, it's
a perfect information game
with a very high
branching factor and a lot
of moves in a particular game.
So your standard minimax
search obviously won't work.
The main component of
AlphaGo was composed
of these two networks--
a policy network
and a value network.
The policy network was trained
to, given a game state,
work out which move the
opponent was going to make.
And the value network was
trained to, given a game state,
predict how likely we
were to win that game.
So naively, while you could
just use the value network
to evaluate your
next set of moves,
in practice that wasn't quite
good enough for what we needed.
So we resorted to a
bit of a compromise,
using these nets with a
Monte Carlo tree search
to get better results.
And the way this
basically works is,
if you do a full Monte
Carlo search, that's
way too many possibilities.
So we use this policy network
to guide the paths in the search
tree to the most likely paths.
And then at some point further
on in one of those paths,
we'd use the value
network to evaluate
how good that path was,
meaning we didn't have
to go all the way to the end.
Why the value network
performed better in that case
is because as we unrolled
these paths, more of the game
had unfolded.
And things were more
certain, so the value network
had a better prediction.
But the real thing
where TensorFlow came in
was the training of this thing,
which was quite significant.
It took quite a
significant amount of work.
So we started by taking
games from expert players
and training this
policy network.
And then we began
this iterative process
where we use
reinforcement learning
to train a value network
from that policy network,
and then update the
policy network to produce
better moves.
Previously, doing this
on Torch, it was slow.
And when we moved
to TensorFlow, we
were able to bring the whole
power of distributed training
to bear on this, which made
the whole thing faster.
It meant our researchers
could iterate quicker and try
new things.
Another cool thing
from this year
was WaveNet, which
we use to generate
realistic audio signals.
So this is hard in general,
because sound waves have
this complex
oscillating structure
with a very high sampling rate,
on the order of 16 kilohertz.
Generating an audio
signal requires
a model which is able to
reproduce this sort of signal
at both these very
fine-grained oscillations,
on the order of milliseconds,
and the whole signal
over seconds, which is
difficult because of the amount
of information.
So there were two main
approaches to this,
previously--
concatenative models
and parametric models.
So a concatenative model
worked by having a speaker say
a whole bunch of
sound, and chopping it
up into little bits, and
then reassembling those
to say whatever you wanted.
What you often see
from these is the sound
seems kind of choppy
because these transitions
between these sound segments
don't quite match up.
It's also difficult
to modify the voice,
either adding a new speaker
or altering the emphasis
or emotion.
Similarly there, the other
was parametric models,
of which WaveNet is one, where
all the information required
to generate speech is stored
in the parameters of the model.
And you supply information
about what you want to say
and the characteristics of
that as inputs to the model.
However, prior to
WaveNet, we noticed
that parametric text
to speech tended
to sound a bit less natural
than concatenative models.
So WaveNet changes the
paradigm that was previously
in parametric models
by directly modeling
the waveform of the audio
signal, one sample at a time.
So as well as yielding more
natural sounding speech
by directly modeling
the [INAUDIBLE],
it means that WaveNet can
produce any kind of audio, not
just speech.
So the architecture
for this evolved out
of work on pixel
RNNs and pixel CNNs,
which were used for
generating images.
And the key piece
of architecture
here was the use of
a dilated convolution
with an exponentially increasing
stride as the layers increased.
What this allowed
the model to do
was to have a receptive
field size that
was exponential in the
number of the layers
in the model, which
allowed it to incorporate
all this into information
about the signal.
The other cool thing
about this structure
is that in the first
half of the input,
compared to the
second half, there
are twice the number
of connections,
meaning it uses that
information to a greater degree.
So here are some
samples generated
from the various systems.
So on the left, we have audio
from a concatenative model,
[INAUDIBLE] play--
the left one, yeah.
CONCATENATIVE MODEL:
"The Blue Lagoon"
is a 1980 American
romance and adventure film
directed by Randal Kleiser.
DANIEL VISENTIN: So
if you listen closely,
you can perceive some
of the discontinuities
in the generated audio, due
to the slight mismatches
in the transitions between
the different recorded chunks.
So in the middle, we
have a parametric model.
PARAMETRIC MODEL:
"The Blue Lagoon"
is a 1980 American
romance and adventure film
directed by Randal Kleiser.
DANIEL VISENTIN:
Which is less choppy,
but it doesn't have
that natural quality we
associate with normal speech--
and so, and finally,
we have WaveNet.
WAVENET: "The Blue Lagoon"
is a 1980 American romance
and adventure film
directed by Randal Kleiser.
DANIEL VISENTIN: Which,
compared to the other two,
is very smooth and natural--
the only slight thing
that WaveNet does
is it has a bit of noise,
due to the sampling procedure
and the neural network.
So maybe if we play
them all again,
just so people can
see, hear, from--
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
DANIEL VISENTIN: Yeah,
just from left to right.
SPEAKER: You want
to play them again?
DANIEL VISENTIN: Yeah, thanks.
CONCATENATIVE MODEL:
"The Blue Lagoon"
is a 1980 American
romance and adventure film
directed by Randal Kleiser.
PARAMETRIC MODEL:
"The Blue Lagoon"
is a 1980 American
romance and adventure film
directed by Randal Kleiser.
WAVENET: "The Blue Lagoon"
is a 1980 American--
DANIEL VISENTIN: Thanks.
[LAUGHTER]
So we compared WaveNet
against other models
through the use
of opinion scores.
And what we found by human
raters, and what we found
was that it narrowed the gap
to human speech by about 50%,
which is great.
And because WaveNet models,
they model the raw audio signal,
we can also get it to produce
sound other than speech.
So here's an example
where we trained it
on a corpus of classical music.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks-- as you can hear,
it's able to generate--
oh, go back one, yeah, thanks.
As you can hear,
it's able to generate
realistic sounding piano notes
on a moment-to-moment basis.
And finally, with what must be
one of my favorite paper titles
of the year, "Learning to
Learn by Gradient Descent
by Gradient Descent," in
which some of our researchers
trained a neural network
to train a neural network,
which I think is a great example
of the kind of flexibility
that TensorFlow offers.
And I think, going
forward, we're
going to see more of this kind
of crazy, out-there stuff,
like with models learning
architectures of models,
models adding bits and pieces
to themselves, and so on.
And so it's exciting to see
that TensorFlow can handle that.
And I know, at least
from us at DeepMind,
that TensorFlow is going to
be our choice of how we model
these things going forward.
So if you're interested
in more details,
you can look at our
website, deepmind.com.
There's a blog post linked
here, which rounds up some
of the things from last year.
And we also have links
to the over 100 papers
that we've published so far.
Thanks for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]